[Musique]
une france plus juste avec lionel jospin
pendant cette campagne dans tout le pays
jeune ou un dialogue avec les françaises
et les français je part de leur
préoccupation je réponds à leurs
problèmes
j'essaie de tracer des perspectives et
c'est pour prolonger ce dialogue que
j'ai aujourd'hui et au cours de nos
rencontres cet échange avec vous
l'élection présidentielle est un moment
essentiel de notre vie publique
elle est l'occasion pour un candidat
chinois un dialogue avec le pays de
l'entendre et de lui parler l'an 2000 ça
va ce sera une étape très importante
j'ai envie d'imaginer comme un monde qui
se deviendra de plus en plus humain moi
je trouve que c'est une bonne question
mais probable bord qu'on règle celle qui
consiste à savoir comment va manger le
mois prochain
être à l'écouté des français comprendre
leurs difficultés leurs espérances leur
proposer de construire avec eux les
réponses les plus jeunes mon principe
d'action et saint dire ce que je ferai
et faire ce que je dis votre chômage
entre donc c'était beaucoup plus simple
qui est déjà du travail pour tous sens
qu'il faut se battre en tout cas
retrouver un meilleur équilibre entre
les salaires et les profits constitue
une nécessité sur le plan économique est
une urgence sur le plan social vous
voyez aujourd'hui dans sa lutte
quotidienne c'est sûr et qui commence à
avoir peur tous les jours quand on parle
beaucoup des problèmes de chômage c'est
avouer qu'on n'est rien sans un travail
il c'est grave bien ça je suis convaincu
que quel que soit les ai pas c'est
plutôt autour de 30 heures que nous
travaillerons au cours du prochain
siècle une solidarité plus efficace
suppose une solidarité mieux partagée
prendre sa retraite ne peut plus être
synonyme de se retirer de la vie sociale
la place des retraités dans la
transmission du savoir et de
l'expérience doit nécessairement ça
contre j'enseigne et je suis parfois un
peu triste en voyant tous ces jeunes qui
sont certainement pas tous choisis je
veux plein de choses pour mon enfant par
mon avenir j'envisage avec j'espère de
la réussite y a plus de grands de
grandes grandes idées aux mamans j'ai
envie d'y croire
il s'agit au lieu de les craindre de
préparer le 21e siècle avec des jeunes
redonner espoir à la jeunesse
il faudra réinventer une politique pour
la ville le droit au logement doit être
réaffirmée avec une politique et un
objectif un toit pour chacun d'abord cru
en europe mais n'oublions pas nîmes sud
et l'est
on s'en rapproche petit à petit mais
c'est encore loin on croit qu'il faut
vous est carrément hors frontières si
c'est pour m'enlever mon travail
non je suis vous le savez profondément
européen est pour moi la france doit
rester au premier rang de la
construction européenne si l'on veut
aujourd'hui que l'idée européenne ne
recule pas il faut que l'europe soit
davantage celle des peuples pour donner
un sens au mot d'europe sociale
nous devons harmoniser vers le haut les
législations sociales suffisent plus à
ascou conformément à la tradition de
notre république et dans un esprit
d'intégration
je proposerai de revenir aux principes
du droit du sol tout enfant né sur le
territoire français est un citoyen
français
oh oui tout à fait
le président de la république est et
demeure un citoyen il ôta accessible il
doit accepter le débat
il doit être au sens fort du mot
responsable nous avons cinq ans pour
construire la france de l'an 2000 avec
vous je serai président de cette france
plus juste que nous réaliserons ensemble
la première préoccupation des français
on le sait bien c'est l'emploi et donc
il est normal que nous ayons cette
première discussion sur ces questions du
chômage et de mes propositions sur
l'emploi
ménagés ce temps j'ai 20 ans c'est la
première fois que je vote pour des
présidentielles et j'entends les
diverses campagnes et les candidats qui
évidemment affirment qu'ils sont contre
le chômage et j'aimerais que vous me
donniez une bonne raison voté pour vous
en ce qui concerne le chômage
je voudrais vous en donner plusieurs et
en même temps c'est logique que les
candidats parlent du chômage parce que
c'est la préoccupation dominante des
français quand je dis plusieurs c'est
que je pense qu'il faut attaquer cet
incendie que le chômage par plusieurs
côtés je propose de le faire par la
diminution de la durée du travail
je propose de le faire par l'
augmentation maîtrisée des salaires
accroissant la consommation et offrant
des débouchés aux entreprises et donc
des emplois
je propose de le faire par quatre grands
programmes de création d'emplois et
aussi par la diminution des charges sur
les bas salaires
vous proposez 37 eur en 1997 mais est ce
que réellement ce sera suffisant pour
créer d'emplois des experts indépendants
viennent de chiffrer ces mesures à
400000 emplois en deux ans 200 mille par
an c'est donc efficace mais
effectivement il faudra aller plus loin
j'ai visité par exemple une entreprise
d'une fonderie dans l'ouest qui a passé
un accord avec les salariés qui
descendent tout 37 eur et sans
diminution de salaire
moi je fixe un cap en tant que président
de la république et je laisse les
entreprises négocier les branches
négocier au niveau du patronat et des
salariés
mais en dix ans la durée légale passera
à 37 heures en 1997 après il faudra
aller plus loin sans doute vers la
semaine de 4 jours ce cric créera des
emplois mais aussi offrira du temps de
vivre
vous parlez de 400000 emplois créés et
je suis chômeuse comme plus de prendre
millions de personnes dans ce pays et je
me demande si c'est pas une goutte d'eau
dans la mer
c'est une grosse goutte d'eau quand même
que quatre cent mille emplois mais en
même temps ça ne suffit pas c'est
pourquoi je propose d'autres modes
d'action je les dis quatre grands
programmes de création d'emplois
impulsée par l'état qui met de l'argent
qui trouve des relais dans les
entreprises mais aussi dans les
collectivités locales dans le domaine de
la lutte contre l'habitat dégradé
pour le logement social dans le domaine
des emplois de proximité dans le domaine
de l'environnement dans le domaine de
l'humanitaire l'extérieur de la france
où en france et ce seront des vrais
emplois des emplois à statut pas des
boulots précaires comme la droite semble
se satisfaire d'un goy de nombreux
français restent sceptiques
comment peut-on à la fois réduire le
temps de travail et augmenter les
salaires
regardez on est en train de le faire en
allemagne dans la métallurgie ou un
accord vient d'être signé
35 heures au mois d'octobre et
progression des salaires modérés sur
deux ans je crois qu'on peut faire de
même pourquoi parce que la productivité
augmente chaque année dans les
entreprises les machines peuvent tourner
davantage même si les hommes et des
femmes travaillent moins donc on peut le
faire ça peut être efficace et de toute
façon les entreprises ayant restauré
quand même beaucoup leur profit leurs
marges
il faut que les salariés qui ont fait
des efforts et notamment les petits
salaires ceux qui sont au smic profitent
des fruits de la croissance donc je suis
pour une augmentation générale maîtriser
des salaires notamment avec un effort
sur les bas salaires
je suis surpris pourquoi lorsque la
gauche était au pouvoir
pourquoi n'at-elle pas réalisé la
réduction du temps de travail on a
l'impression que c'est une solution
miracle qui surgit comme ça à la veille
d'élections présidentielles sans doute
parce que on était concentrés dans la
lutte contre l'inflation la hausse des
prix nos entreprises qui n'étaient pas
assez efficace au déficit du commerce
extérieur
et même si on a diminué d'une heure la
durée du travail de 40 à 39 heures s'est
concentré sur autre chose mais le
chômage envahi tellement notre société
et l'exclusion et la précarité qu'il
faut centrer l'action maintenant dans la
lutte pour l'emploi c'est ma priorité
première
je voudrais vous poser une question que
j'aimerais bien passer aux autres
candidats aussi qui va financer tout
cela
moi je les chiffres et dans des
propositions qui ont été jugés je crois
réaliste il ya naturellement les fruits
de la croissance qui apportent des
recettes mais il ya surtout que je fais
une réforme fiscale et je fais payer
davantage le capital qui jusqu'ici paye
moins que les autres pays européens
je crois que c'est juste et je crois que
ce sera efficace pour le financement de
l'emploi et de l'activité économique
ma priorité essentielle c'est l'emploi
je pense que si l'état se mobilise
les pouvoirs publics si les entreprises
aussi se met en mouvement les
collectivités locales l'ensemble de la
collectivité nationale
on peut être efficace pour créer des
emplois et commencer à améliorer la
situation dans notre pays tous ensemble
dans notre pays il ya une question qu'il
faut faire avancer encore c'est
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
parce que nous ne sommes pas en avance
et il ya beaucoup à faire
les femmes encore puisque les hommes
sans victime de la crise le chômage des
bas salaires précarité qu'est ce que
vous allez faire pour changer tout ça
déjà tout simplement je crois qu'il
faudrait faire respecter le droit
inscrit dans la constitution de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
au travail je fixerai des contrats
d'objectifs pour les partenaires sociaux
afin qu'il négocie pour que les écarts
de salaires diminuent pour que les
discriminations à l'embauché ou dans les
promotions cesse et puis l'état
employeur lui il ya il devra donner
l'exemple
concernant la vie publique on voit que
les femmes sont très mal représentés au
parlement et au gouvernement
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que le
temps est venu qu'enfin elles y trouvent
toute leur place
le temps et d'autre en plus venu que
nous sommes à l'avant dernier rang des
pays européens pour la représentation
des femmes donc les mesures que je
propose c'est la réforme électorale pour
les femmes soit plus représenté c'est la
diminution du cumul des mandats et pour
veiller à tout ça rétablir le ministère
des droits de la femme que la droite a
supprimé nous avons d'autant plus de
raisons d'être inquiète que les actions
de commandos se multiplient que les
déclarations contre les vg contre la
contraception elles sont prises en plus
nombreuses alors comment résister à
cette dérive est la liberté de donner
naissance la maîtrise de leur corps par
les femmes et aussi par les familles
c'est une conquête faut qu'elle soit
respectée respecté par tout les moyens
existent faire appliquer la loi contre
les commandos anti ivg et agir donc dans
cette direction y compris contre les
violences sexistes l'égalité et la
dignité de la femme ce sont des valeurs
très important dans la société une
société démocratique se mesure à la
façon dont elle les fait respecter j'ai
bien l'intention élu président de la
république avec les femmes aussi avec
les hommes de les faire pleinement
respecter
[Musique]
une des questions qui préoccupent le
plus les français on le sait c'est la
protection sociale c'est l'avenir de
notre protection sociale ya des menaces
il faut y répondre chez des propositions
pour préserver et améliorer la sécurité
sociale moi je suis inquiet quand je
vois que le déficit de la sécurité
sociale s'est creusée de 150 milliards
sur gouvernement balladur je suis plus
inquiet encore quand je vois les
candidats de droite proposer des
allègements de charges qui servent à
financer la sécurité sociale sans nous
dire comment il la financerait ça ça
veut dire qu'il nous prépare une
sécurité sociale à deux vitesses et je
ne veux pas d'une sécurité sociale à
deux vitesses il faut au contraire dans
ce domaine faire de nouvelles avancées
et c'est ce que je propose vous proposer
de faire de nouvelles avancées mais
alors lesquels d'abord garantir la santé
à tous
en s'appuyant sur le médecin généraliste
pour éviter les gaspillages et aussi en
s'appuyant sur l'hôpital public qui est
injustement critiqué par la droite
je propose aussi de nouvelles avancées
par exemple pour les familles à revenus
modestes
la location familiales dès le premier
enfant mettre en place des systèmes de
garde améliorées pour les enfants de
façon à permettre de concilier la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale
ce qui est loin des propositions de la
droite qui consiste à renvoyer
finalement la femme au foyer mais jospin
j'ai 25 ans et comme tous les jeunes de
ma génération je m'interroge
qui paiera les retraites condrey 60 ceux
qui vont vous suivre ceux qui seront
jeunes puis à actifs et adultes après
vous c'est à dire le système de
solidarité entre les générations
le système de répartition qu'il faut
préserver car c'est lui qui garantit
contre l'injustice la droite propose au
contraire d'introduire des fonds de
pension c'est à dire le système de la
capitalisation c'est les retraites à
deux vitesses et moi je veux faire des
avancées nouvelles dans ce domaine aussi
en direction des retraites modeste je
propose que progressivement nous
passions un taux de pension de
reversions qu'ils soient de 60% pour les
veufs et pour les veuves
je propose que nous créions une
allocation dépendance pour les personnes
très âgées et je propose aussi que ce
qu'ils ont
travaillé et cotisé pendant 40 ans
puissent partir à la retraite à taux
plein même avant 60 ans j'espère dans un
autre domaine je voudrais vous poser une
question
j'habite paris et je vois des gens qui
ont de plus en plus de mal à se loger
que comptez vous faire pour le droit au
logement à bas une politique différente
de celle de monsieur chirac est monsieur
balladur à paris qui ont sacrifié le
logement social à la spéculation
immobilière
accumulant les listes d'attentes dans
les hlm et les mal logés
moi je propose un effort 5 milliard en
faveur du logement social le façon à ce
que les familles à revenus modestes et
les jeunes puissent se loger y compris
dans les grandes villes et l'exclusion
et les personnes sans abri que vous
allez vous savez que je suis le seul à
proposer un programme volontariste
parce que je ne supporte pas de voir des
hommes et des femmes de plus en plus
jeunes dormir dans les gares couché sous
les bâches dormir dans les caves et donc
je propose que dans deux ans il n'y ait
plus de sans domicile fixe par un effort
massif de l'état de construction de
logements ou de structures d'accueil en
relayant des collectivités locales et
aussi les associations
vous voyez donc il reste dans notre pays
qui pourtant est riche prospère qui
avancent beaucoup d'injustices beaucoup
d'inégalités il faut donc agir pour le
droit à la protection sociale le droit à
la santé droit au logement le droit en
retraite c'est ce que je vous propose de
faire tous ensemble
[Musique]
pour une france juste avec lionel jospin